[Musica]
19 dicembre 2012 per le vacanze di
natale lascio prendo un treno per
lasciare roma dove vivo pervenire su al
nord padova e finché il treno scorre
guardo la bellezza di roma da dietro il
finestrino e mi domando perché da quando
sono nato
sento sempre ripetere potremmo vivere
della nostra bellezza
potremmo e quel termine quel
condizionale che mi dà fastidio perché
non diciamo possiamo addirittura viviamo
della nostra bellezza
potremmo cos'è che non va forse non va
il mondo del turismo non è solo il 13
per cento del pil e l'abbiamo visto cosa
è successo appena s'è chiuso in realtà
il mondo di verde la nostra bellezza e
la valorizzazione di tutto quel immenso
patrimonio culturale architettonico
enogastronomico di tradizioni di
identità e la valorizzazione delle
nostre identità e non siamo proprio
tanto bravi a farlo e ce ne accorgiamo
quando andiamo all'estero no e vedremo a
una guerra questi bravi con quel poco
che hanno cosa fanno
forse perché siamo viziati siamo nati in
tanta bellezza e ci sembra scontato
averla non ce ne prendiamo cura ma poi
questo ha delle conseguenze per cui
quell'epoca lavoravo a report e facevo
inchieste e ho detto va bene fanno
studiare un po questo mondo fammi
studiare capire come faccia una bella
inchiesta ma per conto tuo
allora mi sono messo a squartare un po i
numeri e del turismo in europa ad
esempio per farvi un esempio di cosa
funziona non funziona
ho dato fatto la sono andato a vedere i
numeri delle presenze pernottamenti dei
turisti stranieri in quattro posti le
canarie e le baleari e la sardegna la
sicilia hanno più o meno lo stesso
numero di coste e ovviamente c'è molto
di più anche noi in sicilia sardegna le
canarie hanno 93 milioni di
pernottamenti e le baleari 6 mi 63
milioni
la sicilia la sardegna 7
c'è qualcosa che non va e non dobbiamo
avere i numeri delle baleari e delle
canarie
non è questo anche perché c'è un turismo
bello e un turismo che fa anche male uno
buono e uno cattivo
dipende ma ognuno ai turisti che si
merita perché perché cambia la
convivenza
l'accoglienza con questo mondo di
persone e noi siamo una terra strana
perché la strada per esempio non è di
tutti e di nessuno e da noi normale
buttare il sigarette per terra
dovreste fare poco fa stamattina hanno
pulito tutto un signore poco fa è
arrivato ha fumato l'ha buttata lì fuori
ancora lì fuori un bel mozzicone bianco
e allora perché questo perché non
abbiamo cura la cura dei dettagli è
fondamentale anche nel mondo del turismo
ma realtà tutto quello che non funziona
nel mondo del turismo è la stesso che
non funziona nella nostra vita
quotidiana
il rispetto allora ho pensato che forse
manca la conoscenza del valore di ciò
che ci circonda la conoscenza del valore
della nostra identità perché se conosci
poi la conoscenza porta alla
consapevolezza e la consapevolezza porta
all'azione action c'era scritto no nel
tadic
ti devi difendere delle idee delle
conoscenze delle consapevolezze per dopo
agire e perché agire per creare economia
guardate che la parola economia e
divertente perché deriva da oikos nomi a
nomi e nomos sono le norme le regole le
leggi di cosa di oikos che è la casa la
casa comune è la famiglia e la comunità
questa economia vuol dire e allora il
nostro mondo può diventare una migliore
economia grazie alla narrazione
dell'identità di questo oggi io mi
occupo come narratore e anche come
operatore sul territorio per creare
architetture di narrazione della
identità e trasformarle in economia e
tutte queste
non sono solo parole perché poi
diventano realtà
a sciacca in sicilia in provincia di
agrigento
la provincia più povera d'italia sicilia
la terzultima regione in europa per
disoccupazione giovanile e lì si sta
creando qualcosa che mette in pratica
tutto questo realmente quindi non sono
solo parole teorie belle bla bla bla
perché a sciacca
c'è un museo diffuso aperto un anno fa
un anno e mezzo fa da una donna viviana
vissuto ho detto una donna ecco
interessante non mi viene spontaneo da
una non avrei mai detto un uomo
ecco quanta distanza ci manca ancora per
raggiungere l'equità nel nostro cervello
la parità viviana rifiuto e assieme a
lei e al mio contributo con quello di
tutta una comunità si racconta cosa un
museo a cielo aperto dove le cinque
porte della città del centro storico
sono le cinque porte di un museo
le strade sono i corridoi e le piazze
sono le sale di esposizioni e ogni
finestra ogni porta ogni vetrina di un
negozio è una teca di un museo perché il
tesoro da offrire siamo noi la nostra
identità e questo si può riproporre
ovunque
allora come diventa materialmente
concretamente come si genera economia si
genera perché i commercianti gli
artigiani non fanno più solo vedere
quello che hanno
ma condividono con un non un turista in
un viaggiatore ma un cittadino
temporaneo la loro esperienza ti fanno
mettere le dita nell'argilla ti fanno
fare un piccolo pezzetto al turismo
esperienziale e però significa
condivisione dell'identità e allora
condividere il corallo le esperienze il
le maschere in un posto dove è famoso il
carnevale ma anche el esperienza la
condivisione dell'identità di stefano
turturici che da non vedente ti porta in
giro ad ascoltare nella strada le voci
di suoni del mercato o al porto i suoni
dei marinai e quella e narrazione
dell'identità capite che si può
ripercorsi
proporre ovunque questo è concretamente
cosa genera genera che oggi un grande
albergatore ha deciso di aprire un
albergo grande vicino a jacques cioè
l'abergo c'è già ma ha deciso di aprirlo
a dicembre a gennaio quando di solito
non si apre si chiude invece no lo fa
perché perché c'è una comunità una
comunità formata da tanti e singole
persone che sono diventate consapevoli
del valore di ciò che hanno e lo
raccontano lo condividono quella
comunità offre qualcosa da fare di
interessante a gennaio febbraio marzo
aprile e guardate cosa ci ha affidato la
diocesi l'aci diocesi di agrigento
affidato a una comunità
l'apertura di una chiesa stupenda che
era chiusa da anni e oggi tutto questo è
già scritto non da una persona ma da una
comunità
attenzione questo significa mettere in
pratica la convenzione di far dove che
dice che ognuno di noi ha il diritto e
il dovere di fruire della propria
eredità e questo nostro patrimonio
identitario è la nostra eredità
valorizzarle rispettarla e renderla un
bene per tutti e allora tutto questo che
si genera e che è reale funziona
attraverso la gestione di tante piccole
tessere identitarie che non sono uguali
ed è complesso certo che è complesso e
difficile ma perché abbiamo paura della
gestione della complessità c'è la regola
per gestire la complessità e l'armonia
ce lo raccontano cielo con un mosaico
forse l'esempio migliore perché il
mosaico quando lo guardiamo da lontano è
un dipinto sembrano ma poi appena ti
avvicini scopri che ci sono tante
piccole tesserine riunioni di quelle è
diversa nessuno è uguale alcune sono
simili alcune sono diverse ma stanno
bene insieme perché ognuna al posto
giusto
se nei cambi una se ne togli una cambia
tutto cambia il disegno cambia il segno
cambia lo stato d'animo una piccola
tessera cambia tutto il nostro sistema e
perdiamo la visione la visione di
insieme
allora questo la ricerca che io
personalmente sto facendo ma mi intero
una team intera città
cambiando e per un motivo molto molto
semplice il motivo per cui io sto
cambiando sciacca sta cambiando e sta
creando opportunità di lavoro perché
attenzione creare economia
quell'economia buona nei nostri
territori ovunque si siano dal nord al
sud e questo è il problema dell'italia
significa non doversene andare per
cercare un lavoro quando sei giovane
sceglie di andare ma non essere
costretto e quando non sei costretto ad
andartene significa democrazia allora
l'economia della bellezza attraverso la
narrazione della nostra identità nasce
spontanea per un motivo molto semplice
che quello che accomuna che dome noi
tutti e inter l'intera comunità ed è
essere felici grazie
[Musica]